neither the Americans or the Canadians
have directly said yet where those
identified objects have come from or
exactly what they were but the
insinuation from those Nations is pretty
clear that they believe it's possible
they've come from China Chuck Schumer
the Senate Majority Leader no less has
said he thinks it's likely they were
part of a fleet of balloons coming from
China so all eyes were on this room
today and on what the Chinese would say
in response to that this is the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs here and we attended
a daily press conference that happens
the foreign Ministry spokesperson who
led the press conference was asked
multiple times by multiple journalists
whether China would confirm or deny that
those three unidentified craft that have
been shot down over the weekend had
anything to do with China and he didn't
confirm or deny that what he did do was
respond with a big dollop of defiance
there was a pretty lengthy speech from
him about how the fact that it is
America he says that is the most
aggressively surveilling country in the
world that it is America that other
countries need to be worried about and
he offered this as a new piece of detail
he said that since January 2022 America
has sent at least 10 spy type balloons
over into China's airspace there was a
lot of follow-up questions about when
that happened where it was how did China
respond at the time and he didn't answer
those questions directly but it is
nonetheless a very very interesting
accusation the language also moved a
little bit in terms of the denunciation
that we've heard a lot of in terms of
the shooting down of that first balloon
the one that China does claim was it but
says was a civilian craft that was there
doing weather monitoring he said that
the shooting down of that balloon was
trigger happy he said and unnecessary
and there was also some interesting
questions about that unidentified craft
that China now says is in its airspace
and that the reports yesterday that it
was preparing to shoot that down again
myself and a number of journalists asked
specifically about those plans and it
was a very clear no comment when it came
to that he wasn't drawn at all on any
further detail about the craft that is
over China but really this chewing and
throwing over these unidentified craft
is not doing anything to help repair
these pretty damaged relations between
the US and China it's amazing to think
that just over a week ago the U.S
Secretary of State was due to visit
Beijing that now feels a very way a very
long way off